multi-age at the farm
ER thank you hi uh I'm Smith roganesh
I'm a research director at JPMorgan AI
research and I work primarily on
multi-aging systems and reinforcement
learning
so what I thought I'd do today is give a
brief overview of some of the types of
research problems that we're working on
in the multi-agent systems group
and then I'll dig in into more detail on
one specific project
so we have by the way several different
groups at uh AIR research we have
Danielle from the cryptography group
here and also Parisa from the
multi-aging systems and Auto Group
so that's really a big Focus for our
group uh from the beginning actually has
been the modeling of complex economic
systems and markets and in this area uh
we are very much engaged in using
multi-agent oral and game theoretic
techniques to learn agent behaviors and
the equilibria of these systems at scale
the uh actually open source two packages
uh for agent-based modeling of these
kinds of complex systems so if you're
interested in uh in checking them out
but besides modeling the equilibria of
these systems we are also interested in
optimizing the decision making for a
single agent in this complex system
surrounded by other strategic agents and
uh one example of a project uh in this
category is this collaboration with
Professor from at uh University of
Maryland and here we looked at uh
creating uh defenses against test time
attacks on policies that are largely
launched through communication channels
we're also interested in questions
around mechanism design I saw quite a
bit of that uh in the in the lightning
talks earlier today one question that
props up uh uh repeatedly for us is this
question of fair and efficient resource
allocation
we allocate different types of resources
to our customers
and we would like to do this in a way
that is both efficient in terms of
resource utilization for us but also
Fair across our customers and in a way
that maximizes their long-term welfare
the challenge here is that these
requests for these resources uh come in
at different points in time for instance
they might come over the course of a day
and at the time the request comes in we
have to make an allocation decision
immediately without knowledge of what uh
other demands might come in through the
rest of the day and also in a way that
is robust to strategic behaviors
this is again a project the producer is
leading here so if anyone is interested
in discussing more we can do that during
the break
lastly we are very interested in
developing ways in which we can leverage
domain knowledge about problem structure
and constraints to make reinforcement
learning more sample efficient
now we've found that in applying deep
oral in particular to several real world
problems uh a there is a lot of domain
knowledge that exists about these
problems and B getting deeparal to work
well for these problems is often this
subtle art of injecting this knowledge
about constraints and about structure
into the problem formulation so from a
practical standpoint we are interested
in developing ways in which we can make
this process more systematic and
transparent
so this is what I'm going to be talking
about uh today in more detail
specifically I'll be talking about
um a piece of work that we did around
factored policy gradients where we
leverage structure in multi-objective
mdps for more efficient learning
let me motivate this this problem with
an example
so let's consider a market maker that
prior streams prices for uh different
assets
to multiple electronic trading venues
and at each of these venues it buys and
sells this asset at the prices it is uh
advertising and it ends up earning some
transactional revenue and establishing
some market share
and also as a result of all this uh
trading it ends up with some net
inventory across all these venues and it
has to manage the risk that arises from
this inventory
so what does the market maker optimizing
for it is trying to maximize the revenue
uh aggregated across these venues it is
also interested in optimizing some
function of the market share across
these venues and it is interested in
minimizing risk
now these kinds of multi-objective
reward functions are actually very
common uh at least in our domain I would
say it is it is almost the norm so
there's rarely an occasion where a
business only cares about one thing so
it is a very important class of problems
for us to tackle
and if you apply RL to this combined
reward to find Optimal prices for these
end venues what you typically find is
that the learning is very slow and it
scales very poorly as the action space
that is the number of venues uh grows
as you can see there's a fair amount of
structure in this problem because the
revenues and the market share at a
particular venue depend on the prices
that are streamed to that venue but are
conditionally independent uh of the
other prices but all prices impact the
inventory and hence the risk
so the question is whether we can
exploit the structure of this problem
for more efficient learning and do this
of course not just for this problem for
but for a more General class of problems
so to formalize this uh a bit let's
consider a fairly standard markup
decision process and mdp with a
multi-objective reward so the reward
function or here is composed of M
components
and our goal is to solve for an optimal
policy pie which is a distribution over
actions condition on the state that
you're in and this optimal policy uh
should maximize the this objective
function here which is essentially the
cumulative discounted rewards uh in
expectation starting from different
initial States at zero
a class of methods uh in reinforcement
learning policy granted methods solve
this problem directly by uh doing
gradient descent on this objective and
they use a key result called the policy
gradient theorem to do this and what the
policy gradient theorem States is that
the gradient of this objective can be
computed using the state action value
function that's the Q function there and
the score function of the policy
and in practice you can replace this uh
Q function with any unbiased estimate
and what is typically used is the reward
to go so what is the discounted
cumulative reward That You observe uh
when you start from status and apply
some actioning
and I'm going to refer to this reward to
go or really any unbiased estimate of Q
as this function PSI and this function
PSI the objective will also have the
same multi-objective structure as the
reward function
furthermore we as I said we are looking
to exploit structure we are going to
assume that the PSI has uh is factored
in the sense that the jth component of
the PSI depends on some subset of the
action space so take a con to take a
concrete example maybe you have a
three-dimensional action space and the
PSI is made up of three components where
the first one depends on the first two
dimensions of the action space the
second depends on all three and the
third depends only on the on the last
dimension
to start exploiting the structure in
some way in the policy updates we first
need to represent it
and we do this using a graphical model
that we call the influence Network
so the influence network is a bipartite
graph with the action dimensions and the
components of the objective
and the edges of this graph indicate
which action Dimensions influence which
our components of the of the objective
and this is building on top of work uh
you know there's precedent for this kind
of uh representation in factored mdps uh
as well as more recent work on
influence-based abstractions
now to actually make this work with the
policy gradient updates you also need to
take the policy factorization into
account because the policy distribution
is rarely you know one giant District
joint distribution you typically uh
would write your policy as a product of
some uh some distributions
and the uh this policy uh the factors
are defined by a set of complete and uh
disjoint partitions over the action
space so to take an example here your
policy distribution might be the product
of two factors the first one over the
first two dimensions of the action space
and the second over the Third
but this is quite easy to kind of
incorporate we can group together the
action Dimensions that correspond to
each policy factor and we can now
transform this into what we call a
factored influence Network and this
factored influence Network now captures
the dependencies between the policy
factors and each of these
components of the objective
the one thing to note here is that
policy factorization is actually a
design choice that you make so typically
you you kind of uh you would put down
some formulation for this policy for
these policy factors based on some
knowledge that you have about the
correlation structure of actions and if
you don't have any prior information you
might uh choose to go with an isotropic
distribution
I will not cover this in detail in this
talk but in the paper we also kind of
post the flip this question on on its
head and say okay what given the
structure of the influence Network what
would actually be a good policy
factorization to use and you can
actually derive that from the structure
of the influence Network and what you
see here is an example of what is a
minimal uh factorization policy
factorization for this influence Network
okay so then the key
Insight here uh in terms of leveraging
the structure is that we want to
attribute the improvements in these
objective components only to the policy
factors that are responsible for
generating them
so to give an example if we under some
policy we observe a huge Improvement in
the PSI 1 component and that should only
be attributed back to the first policy
factor and not the second and in fact if
you attribute it to the second policy
factor it's only going to add noise to
its update and increase the variance
so the way we achieve this uh is to
propose a factored Baseline
so the Baseline for the IELTS policy
factor is of the form shown here where K
is the uh by adjacency matrix of this
graph
what it essentially does is during the
update it takes out the components of
the objective that are not linked to
that particular policy factor in the uh
in the network here
and we proved that factor baselines are
indeed valid control variates if the
factored influence network is unbiased
that is you have perfect knowledge and
it is true to the mdp
so how does this work uh in practice we
uh we did some experiments on a summer
toy problem which is the search Bandit
which has been used in other papers
before uh it's a simple problem but it
helps you study the scaling uh of these
kinds of algorithms well and in the
search Bandit problem the goal is for
the action to locate this uh the
coordinate C here and there is also a
penalty for
um
a regularization term on the actions any
case uh in the interest of time the main
the key takeaway here is a factor policy
gradients performed really well compared
to vanilla policy gradients with
State dependent baselines or even action
dependent baselines and in fact action
dependent baselines take about two out
of this orders of magnitude more wall
clock time to run
but more interestingly let's look at a
kind of more real example which is
traffic optimization
and we did experiments on this traffic
grid environment where the objective is
to control the tread these traffic
lights on the grid to optimize traffic
flow
and this is an interesting problem
because this is really reflective most
real world situations where you don't
actually know your influence Network
and here we made a a reasonable
assumption to say that we're going to
assume that the reward terms that are
associated with streets that are not
directly connected to a traffic signal
are not going to be influenced by the
actions of a traffic signal is that true
no uh it's it's an assumption and the uh
the issue with that is that it will
introduce bias in your updates
but what we found in practice is that
the gains that you get from variance
reduction actually far outweigh uh any
bias that you introduce and you can see
that in the learning curves here where
the factor policy gradient with this
localization assumption outperforms both
a joint power policy with global rewards
as well as a shared policy with global
robots
so
you know this this really
um
opens up the question of can we actually
start with some uh assumption about the
influence Network and then as we go
along we update and uh and this this
assumption based on experience and I
want to leave uh end with this with this
uh diagram here because this is really
kind of what we are trying to achieve
which is that we have explicit
representations where we can capture
human human domain knowledge about the
problem uh we can leverage it for more
efficient learning and we can also
refine and update this representation
based on experience thank you
[Applause]
foreign
our next speaker will be appearing soon
is takamitsu Tanaka from Rock 360. talk
is unique challenges and opportunities
in working with residential real estate
data
well